♪ ♪
>> Chris: NURSING HOMES HAVE
BORNE THE BRUNT OF THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC IN THIS
COUNTRY AND SOME OF THE SADDEST
SCENES HAVE BEEN OF SENIORS
PASSING AWAY WITH THEIR FAMILIES
UNABLE TO BE ALONGSIDE THEM.
JOINING US NOW, MARK PARKINSON,
THE HEAD OF THE NATION’S LARGEST
ASSOCIATIONS OF NURSING HOMES
AND LONG-TERM CARE FACILITIES.
MR. PARKINSON, A
"NEW YORK TIMES" STUDY FOUND
THAT ONE-THIRD, MORE THAN A
THIRD, OF ALL THE DEATHS IN THIS
COUNTRY FROM COVID-19 HAVE BEEN
IN NURSING HOMES AND LONG-TERM
CARE FACILITIES.
OBVIOUSLY THE ELDERLY ARE AN
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE POPULATION
POPULATION.
INCIDENTALLY THIS WASN’T JUST
PATIENTS, THIS WAS ALSO SOME OF
THE WORKERS AT THE NURSING
HOMES, BUT WHY BE ON THAT
VULNERABILITY, WHY DO YOU THINK
SUCH A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF ALL
THE DEATHS HAVE BEEN IN THESE
FACILITIES?
>> Mark: WELL, CHRIS, YOU’RE
RIGHT.
THIS HAS BEEN A HORRIBLE TRAGEDY
AND FOR THOSE OF US THAT TAKE
CARE OF OLDER PEOPLE OUR ENTIRE
LIFE, IT’S BEEN THE MOST
UNSPEAKABLE.
WHAT WAS LEARNED FROM LOOKING
AROUND THE WORLD IS THAT
ANYPLACE PEOPLE LIVE CLOSELY
TOGETHER, WHETHER IT’S
CONFIDENCE OR DORMITORIES OR
CRUISE SHIPS OR NURSING HOMES,
THEY’RE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
AND IT’S BECAUSE OF ONE VERY
UNIQUE FEATURE TO THIS VIRUS AND
THAT IS THAT THIS VIRUS, UNLIKE
ANY OTHER THAT WE FOUGHT BEFORE,
A PERSON CAN CATCH IT, SHOW NO
SYMPTOMS YET STILL SPREAD IT.
SO WHEN JANUARY FEBRUARY AND
MARCH, WE DIDN’T KNOW THAT, WE
HAVE VISITORS COMING INTO OUR
BUILDINGS, WE HAD STAFF MEMBERS
INTO BUILDINGS CLOSELY INTERACT
WITH RESIDENTS AS THEY NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM AND WE WERE
UNWITTINGLY SPREADING THE VIRUS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES.
ONCE THE ACADEMIC COMMUNITY AND
DOCTORS FIGURED OUT THAT YOU
COULD BE ASYMPTOMATIC AND CARRY
IT, IT WAS TOO LATE FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND UNFORTUNATELY EVEN
THEN WE DIDN’T HAVE THE TESTS TO
FIGURE OUT WHO HAD IT.
THE GOOD IS THAT I CAN GIVE THIS
MORNING AS WE ARE NOW IN
RECOVERY -- I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION JUST ON FRIDAY
ALLOCATED $5 BILLION, SECRETARY
AZAR, DEPUTY SECRETARY HARKIN,
THAT’S GOING TO ALLOW US TO
RECOVER AND REALLY MAKE THIS
BETTER.
>> Chris: I WANT TO POINT OUT
ANOTHER ISSUE HOWEVER.
THE GOVERNMENT ACCOUNT ABILITY
OFFICE ISSUED A REPORT THIS WEEK
AND I WANT TO PUT THE NUMBERS UP
ON THE SCREEN.
IF FOUND -- IT FOUND THAT 82% OF
NURSING HOMES, OVER 13,000, HAVE
BEEN CITED FOR INFECTION CONTROL
ISSUES FROM 2013 TO 2017.
SO THE QUESTION, MR. PARKINSON,
DIDIER FACILITIES HAVE A PROBLEM
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA LONG
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HIT?
>> Mr. Parkinson: WELL, WE
HAVE A REAL FLAWED SURVEY SYSTEM
AND ONE OF THE FLAWS OF THE
SURVEY SYSTEM IS THAT SURVEYORS
ARE ENCOURAGED TO GIVE
DEFICIENCIES AND WHAT THAT DOES,
IT CREATES THE IMPRESSION THAT
EVEN VERY GOOD BUILDINGS ARE NOT
VERY GOOD.
IT MAKES IT HARD FOR CONSUMERS
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT BUILDINGS ARE
GOOD AND WHICH AREN’T EVERYBODY
GETS DEFICIENCIES.
THAT SAME GAO REPORT REPORTED
THAT 99% OF THOSE DEFICIENCIES
WERE NOT SEVERE, THEY DID NOT
AFFECT PATIENT SAFETY AND MANY
OF THEM WERE JUST PAPERWORK
ISSUES.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS VIOLATES ALL OF THE
NORMAL CONCEPT CONCEPTIONS OF
CONTROL BECAUSE NORMAL INFECTION
CONTROL IS SYMPTOM RELATED.
NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
ADJUSTING OUR BEHAVIOR THAT IS
WHERE WE ARE STARTING TO SEE
RECOVERY AND PEOPLE ARE GETTING
BETTER.
VISITORS ARE NO LONGER ALLOWED
TO COME INTO BUILDING.
EVERY INTERACTION PATIENTS AND
STAFF AND I HAVE ON.
PATIENTS, RESIDENTS ARE NOT
EATING TOGETHER IN THE SAME
ROOM, THEY’RE EATING PRIVATELY
IN OUR OWN ROOM SO NOW THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE VERY VICIOUS
NATURE OF THE VIRUS, WE ARE ABLE
TO CONTROL IT MUCH BETTER.
>> Chris: NURSING HOMES IN
NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY HAVE
BEEN ESPECIALLY HARD-HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC AS WELL AS THE ENTIRE
STATE AND IN LATE MARCH,
GOVERNOR CUOMO ISSUED AN ORDER
THAT NURSING HOMES MUST ACCEPT
COVID-19 PATIENTS TO TRY TO
ALLEVIATE AND PREVENT
OVERCROWDING AT HOSPITALS.
HERE’S HOW THE GOVERNOR
DESCRIBED IT AND EXPLAINED IT
THIS WEEK.
>> THE CDC GUIDANCE SET A HOMES
CANNOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST A
COVID PATIENT BECAUSE AT THAT
TIME THE ISSUE WAS HOSPITAL
CAPACITY, RIGHT?
REMEMBER HOSPITAL CAPACITY?
AND WE WERE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING HOSPITAL CAPACITY.
>> Chris: DID GOVERNOR CUOMO
HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT CDC
GUIDANCE, OR GPU OBITUARIES?
AND WHAT ABOUT OTHER GOVERNORS
AND HOW THEY HANDLE THE CDC
GUIDANCE ON THE COUNTRY?
>> Mr. Parkinson: LOOK, I’VE
BEEN A GOVERNOR IN THE TIME OF A
CRISIS, SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION BASED ON INCOMPLETE
INFORMATION AND THE TIME THAT
GOVERNOR CUOMO MADE THAT
DECISION HE WAS BEING TOLD A
EPIDEMIOLOGIST THAT HAS
HOSPITALS WERE GOING TO BE
OVERRUN WITH COVID PATIENTS.
IN HINDSIGHT WE NOW KNOW THAT
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
THERE WAS ACTUALLY THE CAPACITY
THERE, THEY DIDN’T NEED TO BE
DISCHARGED TO NURSING HOMES.
IN HINDSIGHT, IT WAS AN ERROR
APPEARED IN TO HIS CREDIT HE HAS
NO REVERSE THAT POLICY.
MOST OF THE OTHER GOVERNORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO NOT
INSTITUTE THAT POLICY AND I
THINK THAT’S PART OF THE REASON
WE’RE STARTING TO SEE RECOVERY.
>> Chris: BUT IN FACT HE DID
HAVE A CHOICE.
HE DIDN’T HAVE TO FOLLOW THE CDC
GUIDANCE ANYWAY.
>> I MEAN, IN HINDSIGHT ARE
SUGGESTED TO HIM AT THE TIME WAS
THAT HE DIDN’T DO THAT.
I THINK IN HINDSIGHT HE WOULD
SAY THAT IT WAS AN ERROR.
IT WAS AN ERROR AGAIN BASED ON
INCOMPLETE AND INACCURATE
INFORMATION.
THE COUNTRY WAS TOO CONCERNED
WITH HOSPITALS BEING OVERRUN AND
THERE WERE CONSEQUENCES TO THAT.
ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES IS THAT
NURSING HOMES WERE LEFT OUT.
IF WE WEREN’T GIVEN THE
EQUIPMENT THAT WE NEEDED.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME ACCOUNT
ABILITY FOR ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
THAT WERE MAKING THESE FANTASTIC
ESTIMATES THAT THE ENTIRE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WAS GOING TO BE OVERRUN.
IT WASN’T, AND THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES AND UNFORTUNATELY
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS OR ONE OF
THE CONSEQUENCES.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
THE FIRST POINT YOU MADE, WHICH
IS THAT WE DIDN’T KNOW AT THE
VERY BEGINNING A LOT OF THE
PARTICULARLY TERRIFYING AND
DANGEROUS ASPECTS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS, AND ONE OF THEM IS
THAT PEOPLE COULD BE
ASYMPTOMATIC AND GO INTO A
HOSPITAL WITHOUT ANY SIGN THEIR
ILL AND THEN STILL SPREAD THE
VIRUS THESE VERY SICK PEOPLE.
THE RESULT, AS YOU’VE LOCKED
DOWN, IS WE’VE SEEN THESE
TERRIBLE SCENES WHERE FOR THEIR
OWN GOOD, RESIDENTS ARE KEPT
AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES AT SOME
OF THEM GET VERY SICK, SOME OF
THEM PASS AWAY AND THEIR
FAMILIES CAN’T BE WITH THEM WHEN
THAT HAPPENS.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
REOPENING NURSING HOMES, LETTING
FAMILIES BE WITH THE RESIDENTS
AND UNDER WHAT STRUCTURES, UNDER
WHAT RESTRICTION SO THAT THE
FAMILIES CAN BE TOGETHER BUT
YOU’RE NOT ENDANGERING THE LIVES
OF ALL THE PATIENTS INSIDE THESE
FACILITIES?
>> Mr. Parkinson: WE REALIZE
HOW HARD IT’S BEEN FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FOR RESIDENTS TO NOT
BE ABLE TO BE TOGETHER AND WE
TRY TO OFFER FACE TIME AND ALL
SORTS OF OTHER ALTERNATIVES, BUT
THERE’S JUST NO ALTERNATIVE TO
BEING TOGETHER AND THEN THE
TRAGIC SCENES OF PEOPLE DYING
WITHOUT THEIR LOVED ONES, IT’S
HORRIBLE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
WE NEED TO KEEP THE 15 DOWN IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THE NURSING
HOMES ARE IN.
IF A NURSING HOME IS IN A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS VERY LITTLE
COVID THERE’S NOT THAT HUGE RISK
OF A GETTING TO THE BUILDINGS.
IF WE SPIKED BACK UP AND COVID
CASES THOUGH, WE’RE GOING TO END
UP WITH MORE COVID IN NURSING
HOMES.
ISSUE ONE IS LET’S KEEP IT DOWN
THE COMMUNITIES AND LET STEP TWO
IS LET’S GET ADEQUATE TESTING SO
WE CAN GET A TEST FOR EVERY
STAFF MEMBER, EVERY RESIDENT AND
IDEAL IF WE COULD GET ON-SITE
TESTING FELT THE SUMMER SO THAT
WHEN PEOPLE COME AND THEY GET A
TEST, WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE
COVID-FREE, THAT WOULD BE THE
IDEAL, BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE IT’S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO GET THESE
FOLKS BACK WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
>> Chris: MR. PARKINSON,
THANK YOU, THANKS FOR TAKING